Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
where we left off in
authored by
in the first chapter, the chapter of
sincerity.
The chapter regarding sincerity and
holding a coherent intention in all acts
of worship, whether physical or spoken
or even states of being, both outward
and inward, meaning in the heart and
manifest.
We mention the first verse that half of
the we mention in this chapter to
bolster
the chapter title because as we
mentioned yesterday that the way that
and Noah we set this book up is very
similar to alkari for instance in his
book is that he'll mention the chapter
title that's what he intends to that's
the statement that he
the derived truth or the argument that
is put forth. Then he will mention
verses of the Quran which either explain
aspects of that chapter title or specify
what is intended by the chapter title
then followed by narrations. He mentions
three verses. Each one of these verses
when they are taken together
articulate a very particular
set of intentions that know we had
for this chapter. The first chapter the
first verse that he mentions is the
verse number five from
that is that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said regarding the people of the book
those whom Allah sent the messengers of
ben is too. He said,
"And they were not commanded except that
they were to worship Allah
alone, making sincere to him, or to
worship Allah, making sincere to him all
of their acts of worship in adherence to
the teachings of their respective
prophets and that they establish prayer
and that they give zakah and that indeed
is the right and correct religion
that Allah has commanded. The next verse
he mentions is verse number 37 from
where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
regarding the sacrifice
that is made on the day of
the day of when we make our
people in the time of
when they would slaughter
during Hajj because they made Hajj every
And when they would slaughter, whether
it be for Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala or
for their idols, they would not take
this meat and use it for anything. They
would take it, they would put it out on
the mountain or wherever it is they were
slaughtering. And they wouldn't even
allow the buzzards or the animals to eat
this meat. They would stand guard and
just leave this meat because this meat
is dedicated to Allah or this meat is
dedicated to idol such and such and so
no one is to touch it. They wouldn't eat
it. They wouldn't let anyone or anything
else eat it. However, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala corrected this. He commanded them
to slaughter, to eat of it themselves,
and to give it to
to give it to those who either ask
outwardly or those who do not ask but
are in need or those who have and those
who are less fortunate. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala changed this changed
this about the way they understood
slaughter. He said, "No, eat. Use it.
Benefit from it." Why? Because
he said, "Because it is not the meat or
the blood that reaches Allah from your
slaughtering. Rather, it is your piety
that is raised up to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala."
The next verse he mentions is verse
number 29 from Ali
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
say to them oh messenger oh Muhammad oh
prophet say to them that if you were to
conceal what is in your heart or
manifest it either way.
Allah knows of it. Knows it. Whether you
speak it or you conceal it in your
chest, Allah is fully aware of it
equally.
And so what do we understand from that
verse with regards to the chapter title?
Well, remember the chapter title is
regarding intention.
Intention that one of the prerequisites
of any any act of worship being accepted
by Allah is that you have an intention.
Well, that intention, should I say it?
Should I proclaim it? Should I announce
it when I go to pray, when I go to fast,
when I go to make woo? Why would you say
it? Intentions place in the heart. And
Allah has informed us that whether we
speak it or keep it concealed in our
chest, it is equally known to Allah.
The intentions place is in the heart and
there is no evidence anywhere of any
time in which the prophet or his
companions
ever proclaimed or recited their
intentions for any act of worship. Not
for salah, not for fasting, not for
Hajj. Person They say well what about
when a person goes for they are supposed
to say
a person is to say
or
that when a person begins his journey to
Hajj and begins his he says
this is not an intention. The intention
was made the moment he stepped on the
plane. As a matter of fact, the
intention was made months ahead of time
when you were purchasing your Hajj
package. As a matter of fact, it was
made the moment you decided to go to
Hajj. That's when you made your
intention for Hajj. That's not a
proclamation of intention. That is a
proclamation of the start of your
because we have to have a starting
point, right? Just when a person
stands for salah they say Allahbar this
is the starting point the point of no
return. This is your entrance into the
act of worship. Likewise that
proclamation
otherwise there is no instance in which
a person proclaims or recites his
intention. And you can see this
sometimes you see people that they were
taught I was taught growing up that when
you go to make salah you have to stand
there and you have to say a whole about
your intention, right? to say
and all kinds of things I have to oh
Allah I am standing here to make for by
the way standing behind this im I'm
facing thea the only thing left is to
mention your address and zip code and
why is this at all necessary
not at all and you'll see people that
they are so entrenched in this kind of
tradition that they'll even miss the the
im will go into and they're still trying
to recite their the im gets up goes into
sujud and they're still way behind.
They're going to make intention. You
made intention the moment you laced your
shoes. You made your intention when you
got up off the sofa and decided to go to
salah. You made intention when you made
woo.
Right? Furthermore, what if you
accidentally say the wrong thing?
Imagine you stand there to make and you
say for and then as you're making salah,
you're oh gosh, I said instead of what
do I do? Does is my salah valid or do I
have to restart? Everyone would say your
salah is valid. Then what's the point of
this?
And if my is invalid. Why didn't the
prophet take teach us this?
And this is the opinion of the four ims
of
not in the four med any of the later
scholars of any particular med have made
all kinds of had all kinds of
opinions but I imbuifi
I im Ahmed Ib all four of them agree in
their works and by their students that
procla Proclaiming, announcing, reciting
your intention for any act of worship is
never been narrated from our prophet
[Arabic recitation]
We will end with that.
As I mentioned last night, just as a
reminder,
this evening for
Brothers will lead,
brother Ahmed will lead and tomorrow
morning I won't be here
inshallah
will
Solarity.